hello everyone and welcome to a truly
spectacular game from round 11 of the
2022 tata still chess masters it's a
clash between two now of the top uh
duchy grandmasters jordan van forest and
anish giri uh and it's uh it's just a
beautiful beautiful game i'm sure you
guys already know that it happened but
let's dive straight into it as there is
a lot a lot to discuss so jordan with
the white piece opens with d4 we have
knight to f6 c for e6 knight to c3 and
of course bishop to b4 yeah anish goes
for the nimzo indian defense
and whenever we have the names on the
board we say that okay queen to c2 and
e3 are the
two most popular replies everyone plays
this and that's what you have to do in
modern chess but here uh jordan plays a3
and this is uh something that's
considered a a little bit inferior uh in
modern chess so because now we have
access to all of these incredibly strong
engines uh as it gives a black uh
equality or or even some say even more
uh but what does this mean for human
chess well let's see what happens so of
course now you can capture on c3 and
mess up white's pawn structure a little
bit after queen to c2 you can't do uh
you can't really do that so okay b
captures on c3 and the immediate b6 here
c5 and b6 are the top moves geary goes
for b6 because you want to think it to
your light square bishop or sometimes
you will even play bishop to a6 as now
the the c4 pawn could be considered weak
so maybe we'll just go after it so here
we have f3 white replies that is by
creating a massive center with f3 e4 and
now knight to c6 uh we have e4 grabbing
the full center now
and while you could go for bishop to a6
right away here we have knight to a5 and
this is what we discussed the bishop is
coming to a6 the knight already attacks
the c for pawn and uh this is what uh
anish will uh will try so here bishop to
d3 and now uh bishop to a6 uh
interestingly the position has been
reached in the 2019 saint louis r blitz
tournament between magnus carlson and
levon arun where d6 was played uh the
the game ended in a draw but here we
have bishop to a6 and now comes queen
the e2 we have to uh help defend that c
for pawn and now again the position has
been reached in 2021 between uh dario
olivo dick and theodora
uh where c5 was played the todora was
able to win this game but in this game
we have d6 and it is now as of move 9
that we have a completely new game so
let's see how jordan deals with this he
uh starts with f4 grabbing even more
space here you can see how much of the
squares are covered by those pawns so
that's definitely an unpleasant pressure
for black uh queen d7 on each continuous
development uh
uh is soon ready to castle the rooks
will be nicely connected we have knight
to f3 and queen to a for now so really
going after that c4 pawn and uh jordan
defends it we have knight f2 d2 the pawn
are nicely defended and now anish
strikes in the center with e5 so what's
the idea behind this move well if you
just to win a pawn here because you
can't win a pawn for example captures
captures and captures uh knight the d7
and it's uh well not not a pawn that you
you can really brag about uh we can just
castle here for example castles sorry
castles castles and it's a really really
bad position for white the c pawn is
double the e pawn is doubled uh not not
a lot of fun uh white is very much
overextended here uh with everything
that has to keep an eye on the c4 pawn
so it's just bad so instead after e5 we
have castles here uh sorry castles here
uh in the now castles here so both
players castle we have f captures on e5
d captures an e5 but now rook to b1
and okay the rook definitely belongs in
the b file and you have to be a little
bit careful for example something like 6
c6 rook b4 and the queen is trapped
there is no good reason to play c6 here
but again you have to be very careful uh
so instead of course c5 is played you
really put pressure on black scent on
white center here but now uh there is a
problem for anish in this position by
playing c5 he gives a deadly dare to to
jordan and well will he uh will he go
after it or not uh feel free to pause
the video here and try to find the the
absolute best and sneakiest move for
white well i give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this fine
idea and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is rook captures on
f6 that's the good stuff uh because now
when you see it of course you uh
immediately believe it uh we're going to
give up the exchange to miss a black
spawn structure expose the black king
and now look at white's pieces queen
here knight here bishop here all
targeting that c4 pawn when the actual
game is being played on the king's side
so that's a bit of a problem here so g
captures on f6 now comes queen f3 we
want to grab that f6 pawn right away and
uh well there's just no good way to
uh to go about this if you try something
like knight captures on c4 or try to
force some sort of a trade here knight
captures the bishop captures again
bishop to h6 and you're getting
checkmated queen g3 checkpoint g7
checkmate it's uh completely useless so
any ideas of a game being played on the
queen side have to go away and you have
to switch all of your attention to the
king's side now so queen c6 we're going
to defend the f6 pawn and now d5 uh grab
a few more squares so now we're forcing
the queen to d6 queen to d6 and now how
do you continue this well you have
exposed the black king but none of your
pieces are actually uh joining the white
queen in the attack so we have to free
them up somehow so here jordan starts
with knight to f1 the always the strong
the strongest the most difficult move to
find uh is with the knight back some
would say and now king the h8 uh we're
preparing rook to g8 we're gonna play
rook to g6 also bringing the other rook
to g8 we also might have some attacking
chances along the g file so knight e3 of
course the knight is now coming to f5
and when this knight lands on f5 you
know that you cannot be worse regardless
of the exchange sacrificed so bishop to
c8 we have to keep an eye on that f5
square and now how do you continue
developing well bishop d2 this will
allow our rook into the game but also
bishop to e1 to h for uh going after the
f6 pawn is the way to go here so rook g8
these are basically the only moves black
can play and now comes rook to f1 uh not
right away sorry first bishop to e1
going after that bishop to h4
idea and then we're bringing the rook to
f1 so now rook to g6 adding another
defender and bishop to h4 we have rooked
the h6 again now putting pressure on
this bishop and queen to f2 so not
worrying about anything we're playing
rook to f1 and then we will take it from
there so bishop to d7 now you want to
bring the other rook into the game and
here rook to f1 and now
what do you play here
it's a really really difficult position
and the wider white is of course better
but you have to play it
incredibly precise for example knight
the b7 uh is the is the engine's idea of
how you can maybe hold this but it still
looks very ugly uh point is that you
never really want to capture on f6 if
you capture on f6 black will very
happily trade here captures captures
gives back the exchange and then uh you
you have this end game where white of
course is better uh but white will still
have to uh to prove it uh in the actual
game anish played king to g7 and this is
uh sort of uh
defending against the non-existent
threat bishop captures on f6 was never
really possible here so in chess
terminology it was um basically a niche
seeing ghosts or or maybe it's not even
about defending the pawn maybe you just
want to bring the rook to g8 and bring
the king over to f5 and then maybe hide
the king to the queen side uh regardless
of what the case is this is now
completely winning for jordan and he of
course finds the best idea so what's the
best idea you guys already know because
we said the knight belongs on f5 if the
knight hits the f5 square it's all over
for black so we need to take care of the
bishop guarding the f5 square so jordan
starts with bishop to e2 now bishop to
g4 is coming and then
well either black will capture or we are
going to capture the black bishop and
then play knight to f5 so here we have
rook to g6 taking uh
another uh
um well
uh control of that g4 square and now h3
anish does the same but also by playing
uh sorry jordan does the same but also
by playing h3 he allows this bishop
captures an h3 idea as the g pawn is
pinned so uh what do you play here uh
well giri can basically capture on h3 or
he can uh
ignore this idea and play something like
rook rook to g8 but also this is
insufficient because let's say bishop h5
and where can the rook go to only the h6
square now we play bishop g4 and we
still get our
square for the knight so let's say king
f8 we're going to play bishop captures
on d7 queen captures on d7 now bishop
captures an f6 and it looks incredibly
dangerous for white because the queen
can capture on h3 the rook can capture
on h3 but it is not enough queen
captures on h3 here anish would be
threatening mate in one but there's the
incredible the only winning move for
white here bishop e7 it's not
all that difficult to find because it's
uh well if you don't play this you're
just gonna get checkmated uh so king
captures queen captures and now it's
black who's getting checkmated let's say
king to d8 you're picking up the rook
with check king c7 queen to g7 and now
the rook is coming to f8 so if you go up
the board you're getting checkmated your
only other option is to go here but now
it's knight f5 check and now you have to
give up the queen there are no more
squares captures captures and now you
are getting checkmated very soon so
after h3 uh although uh ignoring the h3
pawn is a valiant but it will it would
not help you so here bishop captures an
h3 was played you don't have a threat
here the knight here is guarding the g2
pawn but at least you're preventing the
knight from coming to f5 or or maybe
you're not because this would also come
with a with a royal fork and black will
would have to give up the bishop here so
here we have bishop to h5 just attacking
that rook uh
there's no reason to play knight to f5
here because you really want your knight
on f5 you don't want the bishop uh to
capture the knight so bishop the h5
attacking the rook uh now bishop to d7
you can't move the rook because the only
square for the rook is h6 and then we
can just capture the bishop so it's a
free piece so bishop back to d7 was
played and now of course we just
captured the rook bishop captures on g6
f captures and now we collect everything
bishop captures an f6 with check king
the g8 and now queen to h4
that's the the correct idea you want to
play queen to g5 you want to pick up
pick up the e5 pawn and then you will
have two connected pass pawns in the
center and even though you could maybe
win the game
in in another fashion this is perfectly
fine now comes rook to f8 anish finally
brings this rook into the game but it
doesn't help him all that much
regarding time on the clock jordan has
some 25 minutes here and each has some
10 minutes on the clock but i'm pretty
sure
urine would win this regardless of the
time on the clock and he starts with
rook to f3 uh you could also just go for
this plan but the rook to f3
isn't uh isn't really ruining your plan
if anything
if rook captures an f3 you're going to
be able to capture with the g pawn so
maybe you even improve your pawn
structure you could also look at it like
that so rook to f7 uh now preparing
queen f8 and now queen g5 there's no
defense you you cannot defend the e5
pawn queen to f8 and the knockouts queen
captures an e5 so now the two pass pawns
are monsters the queen will move and the
pawns will start marching so knight b7
finally the knight rejoins the game so
you can see how it's very interesting uh
from the start anish put all of the
pieces on the queen side going after
that double c for pawn which kind of is
a weakness and that's the idea why it
plays the early a3 we create a weakness
then we we can attack it but then he
allowed this uh rook captures an f6 uh
move and everything just went
downwards so here we have queen to f4 uh
preparing to to push our pawn knight to
d6 and now just e5 we have knights to e8
uh now okay if we push then maybe yeah
we can capture on f6 but it doesn't
matter just d7 uh sorry not e6 just uh
d6 uh if you play e6 here you're
attacking the bishop and the rook but
there's a rook captures on f6 so that's
a bit of a problem if he captures on d7
we can play rook captures on f4 d8 queen
and now uh well it's just not all that
impressive rook captures on f3 can be
played we pick up the rook g captures on
f3 knight g7 black is uh all of a sudden
back in the game and it might be even
better so after 98 we have d6 this is
the correct pawn push and now uh well
you can't simply allow knight to d5 to
this at the e7 check that would be game
over so we have to eliminate some of the
attackers e captures on f6 and now this
is still the idea there's not much you
can do about this so at least queen e8
once the knight moves we can maybe do
some damage with the queen but not
really knights to d5 was played we have
queen to e1 check king the h2 and now
queen to d1 this is already moved 40
time control has been made but uh
doesn't really change anything 97 check
king to h8 and neither king f8 or h8 is
really helping black so it doesn't
really matter and here there are a lot
of ways you could win this but jordan
finds the most aesthetically pleasing
one uh and that of course is rook to h3
uh this is what he played on mu 42 and
it was in this position uh on mu 42 that
anishigiri resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here
so what can you play uh well obviously
you could capture the rook but the
problem with this is that now we push
the pawn to d7 and we free up this
diagonal for the queen to ba to check
and the queen the b8 check always has a
special place in my heart ever since uh
well ever since the the famous opera
house game so it's always uh you know if
it's possible uh everyone thinks about
the queen to be a to check and at any
given position so here it's uh also just
uh completely crushing uh queen captures
on d7 for example now queen b8 check and
there's no defense you have to play
queen c8 and now we pick up the queen
with the knight and that's it uh so of
course that's not possible another thing
after rook to h3 you don't have to
capture the rook but what are you gonna
play if you try something like queen to
g4 white will happily trade captures for
example bishop captures and now knight
captures and g6 king has to go to g8 97
back check king f8 and now even rook g3
and now uh it's uh again beautiful the
bishop cannot move because if it moves a
rook to g8 will be checkmate so you're
gonna defend the bishop with h5 but now
d7 and now you have to decide whether
you want to get checkmated with a d8
queen or a rook or you're going to
capture the pawn and then get rook to g8
checkmate so really really spectacular
uh this was one of the games that we we
had to check all the way to the end even
beyond the point where resignation
happened because that's where uh also
the the beauty of the game lied as most
of the times the
beauty of the game is not
you know within the moves played but
rather within the moves that weren't
played
so yeah that's the game big
congratulations to jordan on this
spectacular spectacular uh achievement
um you know going for a
sort of a sub-optimal line against the
nims of this early 8-3 idea and then
well completely completely crushing
anish you can see that everything anish
played was something that you should
play you you want to play but uh
at that critical moment where uh this c5
was played uh there's no question about
it all of these pieces stranded on the
queen side we go for the attack it
doesn't matter if it works or not well
you know you have the f5 square for your
knight at some point that's compensation
enough and that's all you're the needed
to
start the attack and win this brilliancy
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it and uh you know if you
if you analyze games and analyze lines
and then you have like the top three
engine lights and this one is like uh uh
0.5 for white or 0.7 for white and maybe
this one is a little bit worse than me
you know it's not
all that terrible to go for that a
little bit worse one as it you know
could come as a surprise to your
opponent we are not engines we will not
be able to take advantage of an 0.5 uh
straight out of the opening
uh so
i hope you guys enjoyed it uh i would
like to thank adam chaplin mateo jerojak
uh mike mccafferty uh deepak bhatt and
robert arthur for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
spectacular event until it finishes
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day